[inaudible]
joining me today is the editor
of human progress, that Oregon,
a senior policy analyst at the Center
for Global Liberty and prosperity.
Marion Tupe. Welcome to the Rubin
report. Thanks for having me.
I am a very excited to have you on.
Uh, we've met once before, uh, for, uh,
dinner.
Uh,
but what you're doing with human
progress I think is just spectacular.
You guys are actually promoting good news.
There is actual good news and good
things happening in the world and it
seemingly, uh, is something that
people don't often talk about.
So I think you're doing great work and
we're going to spend an hour talking
about a lot of the good
stuff that is happening. Uh,
but I always like to start with
a little bio on people. So, uh,
tell me a little bit about yourself. How'd
you end up working for human progress?
Well, I was born, uh,
behind the iron curtain and what
was then a communist Czechoslovakia.
And so,
uh,
from early age I started to understand
the importance of political and economic
freedom. Oh, be hit neither, um,
in regular and it pretty quick.
And that's right. And then, uh, um,
when the wall came down in 1999,
uh,
me and my parents went for
Christmas in Vienna. Uh,
that was the first time that you could
actually leave your country and you could
travel abroad as a family. Uh,
how old were you at the time?
I was 13. Um, uh,
because before then, uh, people
still could travel to the west,
but they would keep the, the, the,
the children behind as hostages.
But now that the wall came down
and it comes from collapsed,
you could travel anywhere he wanted.
So we decided to go to Vienna. And,
and the moment that we crossed the
border into a western capitalist liberal
democracy,
it was like stepping out of a black
and white movie into a color film.
Uh, everything was just so much
beautiful, so much more beautiful. Um,
the shops were full, people were
smiling, that was color everywhere.
And, uh, so I think that even
at that early stage of my life,
I started to think about
what makes countries rich,
what makes countries poor. And that's,
I think where my interest in, uh, in,
in all of that started.
Really.
Yeah. Tell me a little bit
about your, your education.
Well, I, uh, went to high school
and a undergraduate in Johannesburg,
South Africa of all
places, uh, because, uh,
when the wall came down and my
parents emigrated to, to South Africa,
they are medical doctors. And so
with our expertise was needed. Um,
so as a kid I got to see both the fall
of communism and also the fall of a part
eight,
which is kind of a unique experience.
I'm very glad I had the kind of
childhood or upbringing I had. Um,
and, uh, I,
so I finished my undergraduate at
the University of Witwatersrand in
Johannesburg,
and then I went to do my master's and
my phd at Saint Andrews in Scotland.
Um, yeah. Well,
what's it like being in these
places when something is falling,
like communism or apartheid?
Because we seem to live in a time right
now where a lot of people think that
we're watching parts of the
west kind of fall. And you,
you've seen some stuff
fall. Yes. I think that, uh,
for the vast majority of the
population in Czechoslovakia, oh,
clearly the fall of communism
was a tremendous blessing.
There was immense amount of optimism,
um,
about the future and also unavoidable
disappointment with some aspects of the
Utopian future that people
have imagined. Nonetheless. Um,
just about anybody who analyzes economics
and politics in central and eastern
Europe over the last 25 years
concludes that people are much,
much better off than they used to be.
And I think the similar thing was
happening for a vast majority of South
Africans, especially black South
Africans who never had a vote,
whoever had political rights or most
political rights and are partied.
And of course in 1994,
um,
so Africa held its first
multiracial democratic elections.
And as a consequence there was also a
tremendous amount of optimism, again,
followed by the inevitable
disappointments as reality set in.
Nonetheless,
it's an extraordinary time of
enthusiasm and optimism and tremendous,
I think, um, that sense of
brotherhood between people. Yeah.
Do you think that's necessary?
That sort of Utopian vision of when things
are changing that everything is going
to be magically fixed and better.
And then as you're saying,
then there's that period
where you go, oh, it didn't,
everything didn't magically
get fixed at once,
but you sort of need that vision to,
to get there.
You sort of need that to
kind of see in the distance.
I think you appeal to a Utopian vision
of the future as you consolidate,
uh, democracy, uh, in,
in, in the case of, um,
in the case of Eastern Europe and as
you consolidate multiracial democracy in
the case of, uh, in the
case of South Africa,
but ultimately utopianism
is the great enemy of, uh,
of, of human progress. Uh,
because I think that human
progress needs to be,
needs to be measured in terms of the
past rather than some sort of a utopian
future. Human progress is an
incremental, uh, process, um,
where you are trying to decide,
okay, is today better than yesterday?
And if so, that is progress. Um,
problems are going to be with us forever.
The question is,
are we actually improving incrementally
in important areas of human wellbeing on
daily basis?
Is that one of the problems with how we
ingest news? Because I was
telling you before we started,
like I went on human progress this
morning and it feels good to me.
I mean the layout of the site is great
and you and the images and the colors and
all that,
but like seeing so many consistently
good things trending that you don't see
anywhere else. And we're going to,
we're going to get into many of them.
Is that just,
is it hard to get clicks because
people don't like the Oh,
things are a little better than yesterday
and a little and the long trends when
they just want the day to day
craziness and headlines and all that.
Yes.
Uh,
I wouldn't be the first one to
point to the nature of news.
Uh,
the fact that news is about things that
happen as Steven pinker always likes to
say,
you know,
there is no journalist standing in the
middle of a city that is a piece saying,
you know,
I'm here in a Luanda the capital of um,
whatever it is on goal. I think. Um,
and there is no civil war. Uh, you know,
journalists go to places where terrible
things happen and their report on those
things.
And so that gives a secured image
of what is happening in the world.
If it bleeds, it leads. I mean, that is,
that is a well known phenomenon combined
with the nature of the social media.
Certainly I think that, um, uh,
Twitter and uh, and, and smartphones,
uh, make terrible things
immediate and intimate. So,
uh,
you know,
we were able to watch tsunami
in Japan in real time.
We saw the destruction and death of
thousands of people in real time,
whereas, you know, a couple
of decades, a few decades ago,
and certainly few centuries ago,
you would never have known that a terrible
thing has happened on the other side
of the world.
Does that complicate your work?
Do you think that that people get
information so quickly that then maybe are
making misjudgments because they're
not looking at the sort of long view of
history?
I'm not sure if it complicates things
because pessimism is part of human nature.
Um, it, uh, it also enables us to, to,
to respond, uh, to the
stories in a quicker time, uh,
to be able to say, uh, on
our website at least. Look,
it is true that there was
in this particular case, um,
so now me and people have died,
but look at the longterm
trends in terms of uh,
people dying and property being damaged
due to extreme weather events or natural
catastrophes. And the train
is, the trend is declining.
So we are also able to use the
social media to, to respond to it.
Um, the, the, the problem is the good
news doesn't get picked up. Yeah.
Uh,
as often as the bad news
because the bad news leads,
uh, the, the good news doesn't, yeah. And
there's just a psychological component.
There might be an evolutionary reason.
We focus on the bad things maybe for
survival or something to that effect. Yes.
John tooby and [inaudible]
from University of, uh,
is it southern California? It's
not about Barbara. Yeah. Um,
they are, uh, they are
the pioneers of, uh,
of evolutionary biology. Uh, they
believe that our brains have evolved,
um, in, uh, at a time in, you know,
tens of thousands of years ago when the
world was just a much more inhospitable
place than what it is today.
Um,
the world where there was
omnipresent danger from, uh,
other tribes from wild
animals, from poisonings, um,
and, um, um, at a time when
life expectancy was very low.
And,
uh,
they like to say that our modern
skulls house and shunned mines and we,
and,
and the kind of psychological responses
that we have evolved for tens of
thousands of years ago,
um,
are difficult to apply to modernity,
which is just so fundamentally different
than what it was until relatively
recently. The, the, the key
period here in time histories,
the last 200 to 250 years when the
world really has changed beyond all
recognition. Yeah. So in a weird way,
are we almost, we as humans are real,
most victims of our own success. I mean,
that's sort of what it sounds like.
Like we've,
we've done so much good.
We have advanced so far that now were
we mitt picco about little things
constantly and think they're massive when,
yeah,
we're not dying of mass. We're,
we're doing a lot with disease,
which we're going to get two and,
and a whole bunch of other things.
We've made our lives way
safer and extended our lives
and all of these things.
So we're almost a victim of
all of that. Goodness. Yes.
So from an evolutionary perspective,
again, the research of others,
not my own overreaction to a
potentially bad thing happening head,
a lower cost to the organism,
in this case,
a human being than under reaction.
Um,
if you overreacted, uh, so something
that may have been potentially harmful,
you all reacted to it,
but, but you survived.
Whereas if you underreact it to something
that was potentially harmful, then,
uh, your gene pool ended
right there and then, yeah.
So those genes that can get passed
on. So, yeah. So, so yes. Um,
um, the complexity of
the modern economy, um,
the complexity of the social interactions,
um,
global trading system for
example, is, uh, certainly, um,
uh, much greater than what
our ancestors were exposed to.
And so it is,
um,
perhaps not surprising that
a lot of people are, um, uh,
there'll be a little bit uneasy or
continue to be uneasy. Then again,
the website is there to show
people precisely how bad
things were before and how
good things are now. So don't
get depressed, um, too much.
Um, there is a good story to
be told about humanity. Yeah,
it's interesting when
I go speak at colleges,
one of the lines that I think does
actually work with young people who are,
you know,
if they're protesting and
they're screaming about
the patriarchy and evils of
capitalism and all of this stuff,
I'll always say to them, you know,
does anyone in this room not have
it better than their grandparents?
And certainly in the United States,
but if you live in the western world,
basically everybody does pretty much.
I have yet to find someone that doesn't.
And I always think that's really
effective way of getting people who,
who are so focused on the negative to go,
oh, something good must have happened.
Because, you know, even though I like
to, to scream about my victimhood, it,
it's a lot better than what my
grandparents had. Yes. I mean take, uh,
something like, uh, like a,
a women's equality or gay quality or
even caring about the environment and uh,
and um, uh, and animal rights or
any more welfare, I should say.
Um, Jonathan Heit from, uh, um,
New York University says that capitalism
actually fundamentally transforms,
uh, our, uh, sense of values. Um,
um,
because or priorities I should maybe say,
because when we are extremely poor,
uh,
which is to say the first
99.9% of Homo sapiens on earth,
right. Um, uh, the, the,
the primary objective of any individual
human being was, was to survive.
Uh, you had to somehow get hold of enough
calories to make it to the next day.
You had to somehow avoid being murdered
by somebody who wanted your stuff.
Yeah. Um, uh, you had to
somehow protect your family.
You had to keep away from
cold, from heat, et cetera.
But in the last 200 years or so,
our incomes have skyrocketed. Uh,
the world is roughly speaking,
adjusted for inflation.
I can't say this often enough because
we'll always have that are not adjusting
for that course. We are adjusting
for inflation adjusted for inflation.
The World Everage is roughly 12
times better off than what it was in,
uh, in 1820. Hmm. So we
have become much richer.
And when you no longer have to
worry about things like survival,
you start caring about
things, uh, like, um,
the nature of the society
that you live in. Uh,
the fairness of treatment of
your fellow human beings. Uh,
you start caring about women equality,
as I said,
you'll start caring about gay rights.
You start caring about animal protection
and environmental protection. So,
um, uh, so in that sense, um, the, the,
the tremendous increase in incomes and,
and general wealth of the society has
also contributed to creating and much
fairer and much more egalitarian society.
So capitalism isn't all evil.
Is that what you're telling me?
People who think capitalism is evil?
I,
I highly recommend that they visit Cuba.
They visit Venezuela there,
visit North Korea in countries which have,
which have taken deliberately a
step in the opposite direction. Um,
capitalism has its problems.
Uh,
liberal democracy has its problems
and it is our task to try to fix these
problems on the margins.
Uh,
but to throw out the economic and
social underpinnings of modernity,
of this, of this extraordinary
age of abundance, uh,
would be a mistake.
Are you shocked at the amount of people
in the West that seemingly want to do
just that? Um, uh, no. Uh,
I'm much,
I'm not in a shocked by the fact that
in eastern Europe where I'm from,
um,
people who are in their early teens and
into the later teens p people who have
never experienced communism,
people who are born after the fall
of the Berlin Wall are now embracing
socialist ideas.
Or at least those socialist ideas are
now increasingly popular amongst young
people. Which day, which is certainly
are and amongst people of my generation.
What do you chalk that up to you?
Cause I don't think it's just that they
didn't experience it as it is. It, is it,
is it just that Utopian dream that we
all have or is it just that it all sounds
good? The endless cry of equality, which
of course never turns out to be equality.
It all is just,
if you don't want to really deeply think
about a system or then communism or
socialism is, is pretty good. Well,
mountain freedom, I like to say that, uh,
that every generation needs to be
educated in the benefits of freedom.
And I think that even filing fighters,
we're talking about something about, uh,
you know, we are always one
generation away from, from tyranny.
Now what that meant was to say that
there is something perhaps
in human nature, um,
that drags us back into that,
um,
into that tribal socialistic mindset.
Now,
there are a lot of different
theories about that.
One possible theory is that
actually as we grow up,
we grow up in a,
uh,
in the only functioning communist,
a communist society or communist
institution, which is the family.
Hmm. Um, in a family, uh,
especially in nuclear family, uh,
people share wildly. Um,
children are not expected to,
uh, earn their breakfast, uh, by, uh,
um, uh, I dunno, bringing home
the Bacon or whatever are,
you know, things get chair very, very
equally and so forth. And that can work.
Um, on a, on a sort of
nuclear family level,
the further you go, the
less it works. I mean,
what you are prepared to do for your
children is not the same what you are
prepared to do for your cousins.
It's not the same what you are
prepared to do for your second cousins,
for your fellow citizens
and for that matter,
for people on the opposite side
of the world. And so, uh, the,
the fact that we are able
to conduct our affairs,
um, uh, on, on a, uh, along these,
along these socialist lines,
uh, in, in nuclear family, um,
doesn't then translate into,
into the society as a whole.
So they may be one reason. Another
reason may be that, that, um,
um, there is some within human
beings within human psychology,
a tendency to want to bring down
people who have gotten too far up.
If you're thinking about
tribal society, uh, or,
or these roaming groups of
hunter gatherers of say,
between 50 and hundred and 50
people, um, where everybody,
uh,
you didn't want all the women and all
the foods to be monopolized by the one
alpha male. So the, usually there
was some sort of a combination of,
of an alliance made by other males
to bring this up on the hill down.
So there would be a greater sharing.
And,
and that was good for the
Alpha male too, right? I mean,
he wanted to survive himself
and if he survived, it is
right. I mean, I mean in, in,
uh, amongst the chimps and so
forth, uh, the, the Alpha male,
that's usually and very poorly.
Um,
so that may be another reason, uh,
and other reasons maybe that, uh,
in the Hunter Gathering Society,
uh,
some of the food would be
shared equally. Uh, there was,
for example, if you killed an animal,
uh, there was no refrigeration.
You couldn't store it. There wasn't no
accumulation of wealth in that sense. Uh,
and so things did get shared amongst
the members of the group. Uh,
plus there wasn't an accumulation
of wealth because, um,
because you are constantly moving,
so whatever your acquired was limited to
whatever you are able to carry on the,
on your back. Yeah. Um, so yes,
the differences between people,
um,
at least to the extent that we are
experiencing now is something that is
probably quite new from an evolutionary
standpoint. So all of these reasons, um,
ensure that, um, and,
and many more ensure that young people
or rather every generation needs to be
explicitly educated in why the
economy that we have today,
which is so different from
what our ancestors have
experienced is actually good
for us. Free trade is a
very good example. Um, uh,
free trade contributes to their
kind of growth and yet, uh, um,
every generation you have a new
push for protectionism. Again,
the complexity of the economy has outpaced
our ability to understand it without
explicit learning. Yeah. All right.
So let's talk about a whole bunch of
these trends that are happening right in
front of our eyes,
but as you said,
they're happening incrementally so people
don't necessarily focus on them enough.
Uh, well I'll let you kick off
the first one. What do you,
what do you think is the most encouraging
worldwide trend at the moment,
or what's exciting you the most?
So the human progress is
unabashedly unabashedly about, uh,
it's a huge human centric,
uh,
which is to say that we consider the
welfare and the flourishing of a human
being, all human beings, uh, to be, uh,
to be a really important of
primary importance. Yeah,
that's an interesting distinction because
you didn't call it earth progress or a
great,
I mean,
the idea was that this is so that
humans can figure out the best place,
the best way to live here, and
hopefully that's good for the earth too.
But that humans actually our number one
here, yes, we can certainly talk, um,
late into show about is it possible for
humans to coexist with the earth and the
animals and what can we do to make
sure that that actually happens?
But human progress is a
humanistic project and, um,
uh,
clearly there is no more fundamental
aspect of human flourishing than staying
alive. And, uh, here, uh,
we have seen tremendous improvement.
Um,
prior to 18 hundreds,
uh,
life expectancy around the world was
anywhere between 25 and 30 years.
Since time in memorial,
uh, as late as 1950, sorry,
as late as 1900 in the richest
countries of the world,
life expectancy was only 50 years.
Today,
globally it's 70 years in do
United States is 78 years.
And in places like Japan,
it's 88 years. So wait, let's,
let's not gloss over that because those
were some powerful numbers. So in 1900,
the average life expectancy was 50 years.
So being in rich countries in rich
countries and rich guide reason,
that's even more impressive, so to
speak, how we've advanced it. So you're,
you're saying basically in the
hundred 20 years since then,
or so we've extended it by
20 years of being slain by,
so two years in, in the west, in which
countries, and by bots and, and, and,
and every,
each person today say somebody living
in Malaysia lives 20 years longer than
rich people did in 1900.
Yeah, that's incredible.
So in 120 years in,
in rich western countries,
we extended life 30 years in 120
days. I mean, that's, that's,
that's almost unfathomable actually.
Uh, it's, it's, it's wonderful.
So that's the first thing is that
people want to stay alive, um,
because they, they, they enjoy it. Yeah.
Can you give me some of the markers
of how we actually did that? Well, uh,
one thing is decline in violence,
which against Steven pinker
has written a whole book about,
um, um, uh, you know, um,
rates of people dying in wars.
I have,
have declined certainly since the
end of the Second World War. Um,
today for the first time in human history,
uh,
there is no hot conflict between two
states that have declared war on each
other.
So we still have a frozen conflict
between North Korea and the United States.
Uh, we have, uh, we have the Russian
invasion of the eastern Ukraine,
but even then, Russia and Ukraine
are not officially at war.
So there's this old concept
of two countries, you know,
declaring war on each other and then
going towards this actually has actually,
well at this stage it has disappeared.
Um,
would almost be unfathomable these days
were two warring countries with full on
wars were invading each other
in the traditional sense.
It would almost be hard to imagine what
that would look like now that that is
very awkward cause that, yeah. Um,
hopefully it stays that way. Um,
one thing to remember about,
about,
about human progress is that there is
nothing predetermined determined about it.
It is not linear. There are obviously
things which can go terribly wrong.
Uh,
the 20th century,
you have the first world war and possibly
the most unnecessary major conflict,
uh, in, in recent centuries,
uh, followed by, uh,
the Second World War and the Holocaust,
the Gulag and what have you.
But the remarkable thing about human
progress and humanity as a whole,
it's, is that at this quite robust,
at the end of the 20th century,
life expectancy are still longer than
what it was at the beginning of the 20th
century.
You are still consuming more calories,
more people went to school
and so on and so forth.
In spite of the 20th century of being
actually quite violent anyhow, since the,
since the end of the Second World War,
a world has gotten
progressively more peaceful.
Then of course you have
medical breakthroughs. Um,
let's pause on the violence part for
just a sec because I think it's one of
those things where you can say that to
people and you can talk all about the
wars that don't exist anymore
and that there aren't, you know,
genocides the way they were in, on
all of those things. It does though,
admitting that some bad
things are still happening.
I think people just don't buy it.
They,
they see school shootings or they see,
you know,
a riot here or something happening
all over the place and they just
automatically believe
things are getting worse.
That sort of gets us to where we started
about how technology is a part of this.
But how difficult is that for you just
to get the truth across to people and
have them actually accepted while at the
same time they are looking at, you know,
a shooting or this or that that they
can just quickly see online. Yeah,
you've got to look at the longterm trends
and try to figure out whether things
in fact are getting worse
or whether this is a blip.
Um, you know, the line of
progress, again, it's not linear.
It has Jagat and um,
and there is no, uh, uh,
once again, there's no
guarantee that, uh, that,
that things will continue to improve.
So you have to look at a longterm trends.
I think the Atlantic around his story a
few months ago after the latest a school
shooting,
showing that actually the number of
kids dying at schools horrible as it is.
Yeah. Um, have been, uh,
on a decline. Um, so yeah,
so longterm trends,
um,
and then having journalists to actually
reported those long term trends that,
that that would be key. So,
so violence is one thing.
It will live in less violent times.
The second thing is that the medical
breakthroughs were absolutely fundamental.
Uh, and here I would point to simply
to two things. One was vaccination. Um,
a guy called Jenner in a Mitt,
I believe,
mid 18th century England.
Notice that milkmaids didn't get,
uh,
didn't get smallpox. Smallpox was
absolutely horrifying disease. I mean,
your body would be covered with these,
um,
with these youth hostels and,
and you know,
80% of kids who got it dyed a up to
60% of adults who've got it, who died,
you know, died. Uh, in, in
the 18th century, France,
it was estimated 95% of the population
got smallpox at one point of their lives
or another, and gender. Notice
that milkmaids didn't get smallpox.
That's because they got a milder
version of the POCs from cars.
And so he started inoculating
people with the POCs from the cow.
And because the Latin
word for cow is a vodka,
our word vaccination come some from that.
And that was a major improvement.
The other thing that happened
was, um, uh, was said,
humanity discovered the
germ theory of disease.
Um,
we didn't know that disease
will spread via germs.
People had all of weird ideas about
humors in the body and me as somatic
theories and what have you.
And it was all nonsense. Uh,
but the upshot of us being so ignorant
about how disease spreads or is that
people, for example, if
didn't wash their hands.
And you can imagine,
right farmer is using human excrement in
order to fertilize his fields and comes
home and sits down to dinner.
Or You can imagine what sort
of diseases literally now, um,
Jews funny enough who washed their hands,
uh,
as part of their religious
rituals at penny to fall, uh,
less sick and die at a lower
rate than the rest of the,
of the European population.
But once again,
because people are so ignorant
about how diseases spread,
they assumed it wasn't magic,
which again led to a pogroms and
discrimination against the Jews. But,
um, even doctors, uh, didn't, um,
doctors also didn't change their clothes,
uh,
because the more blood and Gore
you head on your clothes, uh,
the more it signified to the potential
patient that you are a doctor in great
demand. Right? So, so,
so doctorates we're actually a massive,
a reason or on one of the major
reasons why disease spread.
They went from their second
corpses to delivering babies,
introducing pathogen into,
into, into the body of a, uh,
of a mother and a,
and all that stopped basically after a
discovery of the germ theory of disease.
Uh, and, and, uh, uh, child mortality,
maternal mortality started to decline in
life expectancy to shut up as a result.
Yeah. What else is going on with
the diseases of today that we're,
we're getting close to eradicating some
things that still exist, right? Well,
we are very close to eradicating polio.
Uh,
there are some what's called wild
cases of polio in, uh, in, uh,
places like the Congo. Um, uh,
of course we have, we have, uh,
made HIV aids, uh, or
rather we have, we have, uh,
created drugs of that no longer
make HIV AIDS death sentence.
Um, which, you know,
considering it only took a from 1981 when
we first started talking about each of
the age to about 1994,
1995,
when the first antiretroviral
drugs came along, uh,
only 14 or 15 years. Uh, that sort
of markable accomplishment. I mean,
people have lived with small bugs for
Millennia. Um, so we have, we have,
we were able to do that.
Now the other thing which is quite
extraordinary is that cancer rates are
declining. Now. The reason why
that's so interesting is that
incidentally of cancer increases with age.
So as people grow older and on average
we continue to to increase our life
expectancy, the chances of you contracting
or developing cancer, not contracting,
but developing cancer get much higher.
Cancer is basically just um,
cells dividing, uh, during
a normal process, um,
of, of human body, um, uh, existing.
Uh, but uh, the more
subdivision of cells you get,
the more likely it is that one of
them is going to go crazy and start
subdividing without control and
cause cancer and you're going to die.
And the fact that cancer rates for men
and women are declining certainly in rich
countries, even though life
expectancy is shooting up,
that's again an extraordinary,
an extraordinary achievement because of
early detection, because of better drugs.
Now with Crispr cas nine,
the um, the gene editing, uh,
system, uh, we are probably going to be
able to focus on personalized medicines.
So we are going to be able to create
drugs specifically for one individual or
group of individuals who share. Um, can,
can you explain CRISPR a little bit
just for those that are, you know,
you don't have to give
you a major recreation,
but like the sort of the most
simple explanation of it.
I was reading something on the site today.
Backwards bird. Yeah. Well it's, it's,
it's a gene editing technique,
uh, which is to say that, uh,
hypothetically, and hopefully we're
not very far from, from that. Uh,
from that time you'll be able
to splice out of the genome, uh,
to cut out from the genome,
uh,
genes which are responsible
for a congenital diseases.
Uh, which would be a, which
would be a very nice, uh,
it would be very nice to know
that if a child gets born,
it will develop multiple sclerosis,
uh, 20 years down the line and die in,
in terrible pain.
So these are the sorts of things that
we could do it with CRISPR. Yeah. Uh,
I want to move on to the environment,
but is there anything else on
the mathematical side? I mean,
education is the obvious
example. Uh, obviously, uh,
80% of the world is literate,
whereas most of the time
people were not literate on,
there's now a gender parity
between boys and girls,
pretty much on average in
the world. Uh, again, uh,
something to be happy about because
historically our girls were kept from
education at a higher rated than boys.
I mean, even in Afghanistan and now,
uh, girls are allowed to
go to school, which again,
is a wonderful thing.
And nutrition, I would,
I would really like to end with
nutrition, which is to say that, um,
famine has disappeared from the world,
uh,
outside of war zones.
We all remember those images of starving
children with inflated Belize in
Ethiopia in the early 1980s.
Yeah. And, um, uh, that's,
that's pretty much uh,
disappeared. And, um, um,
uh,
hunger was basically a normal human
condition throughout our history.
And, uh, today, um,
and average African consumes
as many calories as the
Portuguese did in the early
1960s.
Just about everywhere in the world,
people are consuming more calories than,
uh,
than what the USDA recommends,
should be the average intake.
And in, in Africa, they are
certainly reaching that threshold.
And Africa is important because
that's really where absolute poverty,
um, continues to be a major problem. Um,
I think it's fair to say that
absolute poverty is, uh, going to,
is ending as a global problem. It
is now going to remain as a, as a,
as a, uh, as an African problem. Um,
that is concentrated in a couple
of African country in, in,
in a few African countries,
including places like the Congo.